I saw a lot of people today smoking  cigarettes and drinking coffee at the  same time now does anybody in here smoke  cigarettes and drink coffee at the same  time you say though you do that and do  you do it in public or do you do it at  your house at your home right because I  saw people in public doing it and at  home I understand it but public I don't  get it because guys if you're smoking a  cigarette and drinking coffee at the  same time you're basically saying I  would like to [ __ ] right now  right [ __ ] now like don't be you  better get out of [ __ ] way I'm  [ __ ] right now right so to do that  in public is risky that's all I'm saying  that's a game of chutes and ladders I'm  not playing with my [ __ ] [ __ ] you  look at that seeds you must do a Kegel  with your [ __ ] Fred to be that strong  I don't control I guess I don't know  [Music]  you